hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe I'm your host Sean
Carroll I wanted to express my
appreciation for those of you who have
stuck with it this far I know that the
last three videos in particular a series
building up some fundamental ideas from
quantum field theory they can get pretty
abstract they can get pretty challenging
not because they're intrinsically hard
but because they're very different from
what we're usually used to either in our
everyday lives or even in our first
elementary physics courses okay so I
thought we would get a little break
today a little bit of a palate cleanser
there's some big ideas in here
absolutely but I wanted something a
little bit more tangible that we could
sort of relate to things we're familiar
with so today's big idea is scale this
is a very big idea indeed but it is no
less profound as we will see than the
other ideas scale is just the size of
things and it particularly you might ask
how different sizes of things depend on
other variables if you change one thing
how do other things scale with them is a
question that we often ask we've already
talked about this of course a little bit
especially in the last video and we
normalization we talked about the fact
that you could put an ultraviolet cutoff
in your quantum field theory and that
sort of sets a scale an energy or a
wavelength scale beyond which you say we
don't know what's going on we don't know
what the laws of physics are and Ken
Wilson and others figured out ways to
nevertheless do physics below those
energies without knowing physics above
those energies and this raises the fact
that in particle physics in particular
and in quantum field theory there are a
set of scales characterized by nature or
maybe the other way around nature is
characterized by a set of scales so I
want to talk about that a little bit
today but of course because this is what
we do here I want to dig in a little bit
more to where some of these skills come
from and how they relate to each other
it turns out that the whole idea of
where scales come from is enormous and
difficult and we're not going to get to
all the different scales and some that
we don't know some of them we do know
we'll have to wait a little bit to
figure out where they come from so when
I talk about the size of things what is
that supposed to mean well it depends on
what units you're thinking about right
size could mean length of course
could just mean distance but it also
mean any combination of lengths so area
is length squared volume of course but
then of course you also have time right
space-time we know is one thing so if
you can measure lengths you can measure
time and then we have mass we have
energy we have a whole bunch of
different ways in which you could talk
about the size of different things the
size of the energy scale the size the
mass scale so we are highly-trained
particle physicists so we will use
natural units and that will make our
lives much easier and I'm not sure why
it was the particle physicist who got to
come up with the name natural units
there's a whole bunch of unit systems
out there we can use so we set h-bar
plunks constant the reduced Planck's
constant with the two pi in it equals
one and the speed of light C also equals
one and then we need to pick a unit
right we need to pick one unit to
actually stick with so we know we went
over before is that the units of energy
in natural units are the same as the
units of mass and that's because you
know that there's an equation e equals
MC squared and if the speed of light is
equal to one then energy just equals
mass you could equally well to make that
argument use the equation for kinetic
energy right equals MC squared is the
rest energy the kinetic energy in
nonrelativistic physics is e equals
one-half MV squared and the half is
dimensionless M still has a dimensions
of mass and if the speed of light is
equal to one that means every velocity
is dimensionless because every velocity
is measured in the fractions of the
speed of light so e equals one-half MV
squared also tells you that in natural
units energy and mass have the same
units and we're gonna measure them using
electron volts evey okay I will explain
a little bit I gave the technical
definition of electron volt you have a
vault of electrical potential it
requires one electron volt of oomph
of energy to move it across that one
volt of potential let's say between the
ends of a one volt battery
I guess that's completely meaningless
who does that in their everyday life
moving electrons across one volt
batteries but will give you a feeling
for how
much an electron volt is during this
video bye-bye
sort of comparing it to other things
that we actually have feelings for
sometimes we use GeV G 4 Giga this is
billion electron volts okay so 10 to the
9 electron volts in fact particle
physicists are shameless about using
electron volts but also GeV 4 billion
electron volts but also MeV with a
capital M 4 mega electron volts 10 to
the 6 ke V kill electron volts 10 to the
3 MeV with a lowercase M means milla
electron volts 10 to the minus 3 TV tera
electron volts etc I'm gonna try to
mostly use electron volts sometimes I
will use GeV because I'm so used to
using GeV for certain things that that's
what I just understand the units in the
different quantities but I'm gonna try
it like if you don't know it I'm gonna
try to make your life easier by just
sticking with evey most of the time and
then you have you know space and time so
length and time have units of 1 over
energy so we will measure those in units
of 1 over electron volts so if you wanna
know how tall somebody is you can give
their height in inverse electron volts
okay that's one of the lessons of this
lecture and the conversions in in
natural units just to relate to more
natural things one gram interestingly
you know there's not a unit of energy
that everyone is familiar with like
probably the unit of energy most people
are familiar with is the kilowatt hour
how many kilowatts you use in an hour
sorry say the way around kilowatts times
a number of hours so kilowatt is a rate
at which you're using energy so if you
go to your electrical meter outside it
measures the rate which you're using
energy and then it integrates it over
time to get kilowatts times hours and
that's even to total energy but also
completely bizarre unit of energy in CGS
units centimeters gram seconds energies
measured in eggs in MKS meters kilogram
seconds its measured in joules but very
few people have a feeling for either
what an ERG
jool actually is so I'm not gonna tell
tell you how to convert but there it is
electron volt so you can just look it up
I will tell you how to convert grams
gram one gram is approximately ten to
the thirty three electron volts and just
to reiterate that I'm very much a
theoretical physicist here we are going
to use one significant figure in all our
calculations so of course there's a much
more precise number relating grams to
electron volts but since we only really
care about the basic way that things
relate to each other we're not gonna be
plugging in and doing building any
machines based on this I'm just gonna
give you the order of magnitude here
okay so one gram ten to the thirty three
electron volts so as a mass one electron
volt is really really tiny okay one
electron volt is ten to the minus 33
grams and grams are pretty tiny a gram
is the mass of one cubic centimeter of
water and a cubic centimeter is about a
fifth of a teaspoon for you Americans
out there so a gram is a very tiny
amount of mass electron volts are much
tinier than that one centimeter is
approximately what do I have here you
can write it two different ways
ten to the five inverse electron volts
right as I said the units of length and
natural units are inverse electron volts
but sometimes it's more convenient to
write this as the quantity ten to the
minus five electron volts to the minus
one power okay so if you're using units
of inverse evie one centimeter is ten to
the five of them 100,000 of them but
what you want is sort of some sort of
physical relationship right if someone
is quoting you a length in electron
volts you want to know like okay what is
the length that one electron volt
corresponds to or vice versa
what are the number of electron volts
that one centimeter corresponds to so
one centimeter corresponds to ten to the
minus five electron volts to the inverse
powers as well see when we dig in a
little bit you'll get a little bit more
of a physical feeling for what that
actually means and one second
traditional unit of time is about 10 to
the 15 inverse electron volts so in
other words 10 to minus 15
electron volts to the minus one power so
time and space relate to each other by C
equals one it should not be a surprise
to you that one centimeter corresponds
to a much smaller number of inverse
electron volts than one second because
in one second the speed of light says
that light is gonna move a lot more than
one centimeter right it's gonna be a
very big distance so one second in
energy units corresponds to a much much
much tinier energy than one centimeter
does okay so that now with those in hand
we can do the traditional thing this has
been done many times the powers of ten
kind of diagram and I don't want to
belabor it too much but I know that some
people been asking in the videos you
know like the Planck scale what is that
or you know how what is an electron
compared to a proton things like that so
we can actually just go over these very
very quickly if I can get them right I
think we'll be in good shape here so I
think I can draw this this way let's see
okay it's a that's close enough to a
straight line and I'm gonna cheat not
cheat a little bit but I'm gonna ask
your indulgence a little bit you know
what I want to talk about thirty orders
of magnitude of difference between
energies at the low end I'm gonna say
that this is 10 to the minus 3 electron
volts and I want to go all the way up to
10 to the 27 electron volts okay so
that's why I've divided into three
because then by powers of 10 this is 10
to the 7 electron volts and this is 10
to the 17 electron volts okay
sadly 10 is an awkward number we only
pick it because we have 10 fingers so
what I'm gonna do is draw one two little
subdivisions and they're gonna go by 3
and then by 4 right does this make sense
so this is I'm at the right smaller I
suppose 10 to the well this is just one
one electron volt this is 10 to the 3
electron volts then so that's 3 between
there and there another 3 between there
and 3 between there and there 3 between
there and therefore between there and
there that's what I'm trying to say here
then same thing here so this is 10 to
the
and Evi 10 to the 13 Evy same thing here
this is ten to the 20 Evy 10 to the 23
Evy okay this is just the way that I
thought that would be most convenient to
actually do this and then want to tell
you where the different masses of
particle physics are so for example an
electron has a mass of about 500,000
electron volts so I'm tempted to just
call that a million electron volts but
that factor of two kind of really does
matter so it's a little bit less than a
million electron volts so let's put it
here this is the mass of the electron so
what I'm gonna do here to start is
convert masses into energies and just
tell you where the mass scales are and
then we'll talk about some real energies
later so this is 5 times 10 to the 5
electron volts so a capital M evie is a
million electron volts mega electron
volts you will often see the electron
mass written is 0.5 MeV okay whereas
protons and neutrons are about 1 GeV
about 1 billion electron volts so that's
here write it like there okay so this is
protons neutrons and that's 10 to the 9
electron volts 1 GeV 1 Giga electron
volt and then things like the Higgs
boson which is 125 GeV the top quark is
174 so again ignoring anything other
than the order of magnitude that is 10
to the 2 times the GeV so it's 10 to the
11 electron volts okay so that's here
this is Higgs top quark is about the
same 10 to the 11 electron volts okay
and then everything that we know in the
standard model of particle physics is
mostly in between right things like
muons and Tau's are in between electron
and Higgs all the quarks are in between
here so this is basically the range
that's it and you might ask well why do
we have to go all the way from 10 to the
minus 3 to 10 to 20 710 and 27 electron
volts is of course the Planck scale
this is what we call the reduced Planck
scale there's a factor of four pi or
something like that that goes in there
but 10 to the 18 GeV or ten to twenty
seven electron volts is about what we
mean so you can see the huge range you
know this it covers a lot of sins the
fact that we put 30 orders of magnitude
into this picture this is an enormous
difference between the mass of the Higgs
and something like the Planck scale okay
it's a really big difference but there
it is and it's important once gravity
comes into the game and you can
instantly see sort of why gravity is not
important in particle physics the Planck
scale the Planck energy is basically the
energy at which you would have to do
some particle collisions before gravity
became noticeable compared to the other
forces of nature and here we are doing
experiments that let's say the Large
Hadron Collider it is roughly here you
know ten or a hundred orders of
magnitude sorry ten or a hundred times
bigger
what is the LHC something roughly
speaking at this order magnitude level
ten T V so 10,000 GeV so that is 10 T V
is 10 to 12 10 to 13 yeah there we go
10 to the 13 Evie so let's say this is
where we'll put the LHC I really should
sort of rehearse and playing these
lectures a little bit better okay and
then of course you have things like
atomic nuclei right like an atomic
nucleus is typically a collection of
protons and neutrons it's always a
collection of protons and neutrons so
nuclei sort of span some range here so
as all the physics that we know is in
this little range except there is of
course at the neutrino right neutrinos
there's three of them electron neutrino
muon neutrino tau neutrino neutrinos are
remarkably complicated and subtle
actually even though I say there's three
of them there's also three different
masses for neutrinos the lightest one
the middle one and the heaviest one but
there's something called neutrino mixing
that says that the lightest neutrino is
not the electron neutrino it's a
combination of the electron the muon and
the Tau neutrino and likewise for the
middle one and likewise for the heaviest
one there's not a one-to-one line up
between what we call the flavor
of the neutrino are they electoral honor
they muon or they tell what that means
is are they produced along with those
particles so when the muon decays it can
turn into an electron but only at the
cost of making a muon neutrino so the
muon miss is conserved and then an
electron antineutrino so electron this
is not created and those flavor states
of neutrinos do not line up with the
mass States and this is why neutrinos
are complicated but we don't even know
what the masses are we think that
they're somewhere in between 10 to the
minus 3 and 1 electron volts that's why
I need to go down all the way here and
also interestingly there's another
parameter that is down there which is
remember we talked about the
cosmological constant the vacuum energy
that pushes apart the universe so we
said that there is an energy density Rho
lambda equals the energy density and
empty space the amount of energy in any
one cubic centimeter or something like
that and so that has units of energy to
the fourth power so we can write it as
some energy scale Evac to the fourth
power
and you run through the numbers you
compare to the observations that we've
made and Evac turns out to be about 10
to the minus 3 electron volts so that's
not the mass of any particle okay that's
not the mass of anything that is the
scale that is the energy scale that you
raised to the fourth power to get this
number the energy density of the vacuum
but that's okay this wonderful thing
about natural units is we can compare
energies and other scales and masses all
to each other at the same time now you
might say hmm it's interesting that the
energy density of the vacuum is at the
same energy scale as the mass of the
neutrinos just I'd have anything to do
with anything else no one knows because
no one knows what the explanation for
the vacuum energy actually is but you
would not be the first to try to relate
them if you went out and made a theory
that had them related to each other okay
what else can we talk about well we
don't know what the dark matter is okay
we're not
or what the dark matter is but there are
ranges of possibilities for the dark
matter
so one range one particle that could be
the dark matter is the acción accion's
could be maybe 10 to minus 4 electron
volts very very light particles some of
you we haven't gotten into cosmology in
detail yet but some of you might know
that one of the things we know about the
dark matter is that it's cold and moves
slowly and you might say well I would
think that light particles should be
moving fast because they're light so
even a little bit of energy would make
them move very rapidly why our accion's
qualifying as cold dark matter the
answer is that they're made with zero
momentum from the start when the
accion's are born they're born at rest
and this is a complicated story about
accion's which makes them very
interesting to cosmologists the other
possibility is that the dark matters up
here sort of LHC type scales ok so if
you have weakly interacting massive
particles wimps
I should put question marks here because
we don't know if these particles exist
but wimps could be at the scale where
the Large Hadron Collider is looking
maybe a little bit less than that
actually to be to be honest because the
hope is that you have more than enough
energy to make them so let me be a
little bit more honest there and put the
wimps up here ok they might be
comparable to the Higgs a bit less than
the things we don't know there could be
as much as a proton or something like
that and then there's this idea called
grand unification there's this idea that
we don't know if it's true it became
very popular 1970s because there's four
forces of nature that we can easily
recognize gravity electromagnetism the
weak nuclear force and the strong
nuclear force in some sense you can
qualify electro and magnetism is two
different forces but Maxwell unified
those back in the 1800s so we call them
one force in the 1960s Steven Weinberg
played this trick where he showed how to
unify the electromagnetic force with the
weak nuclear force to create what we now
called the electroweak theory and the
energy scale of the electroweak theory
is about these energies we've been
talking about like somewhere around the
Higgs boson the LHC etc okay a hundred
GeV or ten to the 11 electron volts
that's a typical scale for the
electroweak force now gravity has always
been hard gravity is a hard thing to put
into the quantum mechanical framework
but the strong force is perfectly
quantum field theory so an obvious next
thing to do is to do what Weinberg did
but do it again rather than just
unifying electromagnetism in the weak
forest unify it with a strong force as
well and that attempt was called grand
unification so grand unification doesn't
even include gravity it's just supposed
to be the electromagnetic weak and
strong forces and what you can do is
predict using physics etc that there's a
typical energy scale the grand unified
theory energy scale again question mark
times we don't even know if it's true
but it's something two orders of
magnitude maybe three orders of
magnitude below the Planck scale 10 to
the 10 to the 23 24 25 electron volts
again we don't know so there's some some
wriggle room there so this would be the
scale at which all the different forces
differentiated or at least the strong
force differentiated from the weak from
the electroweak force then electricity
magnetism differentiate from the weak
force down here near where the Higgs
boson is so this is something that again
is hard to probe experimentally it's
very hard to build a particle
accelerator that reaches those energies
the hope of grand unification was that
because it unified everything it gave
you a way for protons and neutrons to
decay into particles that were not
strongly interacting at all now neutrons
decay all the time but they decay into
protons protons according to every
experiment we've ever done don't decay
at all but according to grand unified
theories they should decay so people
started building proton decay
experiments and they were very
disappointed that the proton is not
observed to decay this was sort of this
is you know since the 80s we've been
looking for this and haven't found it
this is the first hint that our attempt
to go beyond the electroweak theory
haven't been paying off yet and that's
still true you know forty years later so
what you get is in between here and here
in these theories you get what is called
a desert sometimes called class shows
desert after Sheldon Glashow
who was one of the people along with
Howard
Jehu was an originator of the grand
unification idea the idea that maybe
down here near ten to the ten evey ten
to the twelve evey there's a whole bunch
of particles and there's nothing new
going on until you reach the grand
unification maybe that is true maybe it
is not we don't know we haven't looked
yet but there is this big gap in scales
that is one thing that I absolutely
wanted to emphasize to you so there's
another thing okay so this is basically
this is the powers of 10-story at the
particle physics level okay it would be
nice to relate these to some more
tangible things most of us have never
seen proton with our naked eye most of
us have never seen the Planck scale with
our naked eye or anything like that how
do you relate these like it's just a lot
of energy or a little bit of energy okay
so let me give you two different scales
you can compare to let's make another
color here what if you clap your hands
like that I mean not like that because
that's very slow what if you clap your
hands as fast as you can right you know
do your best to move your hands as fast
as you can I don't know if this is if I
got this right but this is the homework
I did for you folks I sat down and I
calculated the kinetic energy involved
in clapping your hands together don't
trust me on this I'm not very good at
those kinds of back-of-the-envelope
calculations but the answer I got was
that a clap is around here this is the
kinetic energy you get by clapping your
hands together the energy released and
sound and heat when you clap your hands
together it's about 10 to the 18
electron volts okay and if you have a
sort of medium sized jet airliner or a
very big freight train loaded and
they're moving at you know 100 miles an
hour or whatever they move at those will
have an energy that is basically the
Planck scale either I think of Boeing
767 was what I read trains of course
depends on how much you've load them how
fast they go cetera but the kinetic
energy but you pack into a moving train
or plane is about the Planck scale so on
the one hand the Planck scale is a lot
of energy like you don't want to get hit
by moving freight train
but on the other hand you can clap your
hands together and you create more
energy than any particle accelerated by
the Large Hadron Collider oh you might
be wondering like why do we spend 9
billion dollars to accelerate particles
to these energies when I can create much
more energy just by clapping my hands
the answer of course is that the amazing
thing about the LHC is not that the
energies are high but that they are
packed into a single particle likewise
for the Planck scale up here the amazing
thing is not that the energy is just
enormous ly big but that it is perhaps
packed into a single particle or at
least packed into a single energetic
event whatever is happening at the
Planck scale the first excited modes of
superstrings would have energies near
the Planck scale and that would have in
a single particle the energy of a moving
freight train okay so that's why it is
so much energies it's a lot of energy in
one little tiny package that's why it's
hard to make I mean you can smash
airplanes together all you want the
total energy might be of the order the
Planck scale but you're not
concentrating them into one particle all
the individual protons or neutrons that
are hitting each other will have
energies way way below the Planck scale
so no interesting quantum gravitational
effects are going to take place okay
another way of comparing these energy
scales and particle physics to everyday
scales is to compare masses to energy
right so so as far as masses are
concerned let me get this out of the way
because you already saw that and I need
the space so to compare masses to
energies remember that as far as mass is
concerned one proton is about the same
as one Neutron and that's about 1 GeV
which is 10 to the 9 electron volts for
comparison purposes an electron is about
118 hundredths of a proton in terms of
mass
okay so when you make up ordinary matter
almost all of the matter almost all the
mass comes from electrons
comes from protons and neutrons comes
from the nuclei electrons are important
for the chemical and electrical
properties of the matter but as far as
the mass is concerned forget about the
electrons it's all the actions in the
protons and neutrons and conveniently
protons and neutrons are about the same
mass if you're a little bit more careful
here I'm going to get the numbers wrong
but I think that the proton is 0.93
eight of a GeV and the neutron is 0.93
nine of a GeV it's just a little tiny
bit more than that but to our precision
we're going to talk talk about it as
just one GeV and then you know let me
get this right okay a gram a gram is ten
to the thirty three electron volts so
one gram of mass ten to the thirty three
electron volts so that's ten to the 33 -
924 proton masses so ten to the thirty
three electron volts doesn't even fit on
our plot right one gram one-fifth of a
teaspoon of water has more energy in it
by which we mean if you literally
converted all of that rest energy all of
the energy like we did a nuclear
explosion but better than nuclear
explosion if you had half of a gram of
matter and half of a gram of antimatter
and combine them together and they
completely annihilated the energy
released would be ten to the 33 electron
volts so that little tiny bit of mass by
every day scales has an enormous amount
of energy by particle physics scales
that's the point I'm trying to get to
and this number ten to the thirty three
electron volts might actually secretly
be familiar to you because I've been
hiding it by not doing the precision but
there is something called Avogadro's
number
Avogadro's number is useful in chemistry
just by fixing a certain amount of stuff
but it's also useful as a rough
for when things become macroscopic and
everyday in typical things that you know
about one centimeter across you might
get roughly speaking of a God rose
number of particles okay or of atoms in
them and Avogadro's number is let me get
it to one significant figure six times
10 to the 23 six times ten to the 23
when you round up is 10 to the 24
that's what Avogadro's number is it's
roughly speaking the number of hydrogen
atoms in one gram of hydrogen or if you
have something like carbon which is
actually used as the as the mass
standard here Avogadro's number is the
number of carbon atoms in 12 grams of
carbon because the atomic weight of
carbon is 12 okay
chemists bless their hearts care about
the real world where there are isotopes
and so they care about the fact that you
know hydrogen is not all atoms that have
one proton and one electron
sometimes there's deuterium with a
proton and a neutron or even tritium
with a proton and two neutrons we
physicists can ignore that and imagine
the spherical cow where all hydrogen
atoms are one proton and one electron
but Avogadro's number is roughly
speaking the number of atoms or the
number of particles in a gram or a few
grams worth of stuff okay so of a God
Rose number is the connection between
microscopic numbers protons and neutrons
and their masses and macroscopic numbers
grams and cubic centimeters and things
like that now what we could do is redo
this powers of 10 plot by the way I
should just for sake mention that this
is a logarithmic plot that is to say the
distance between the different tick
marks is not a fixed amount of energy
it's a fixed scaling in energy right
every tick mark the energy goes up by 10
to the 3 as a multiplicative power and
we'll get back to that a little bit
later maybe depending on how long this
video goes so you can do this again and
you can do this for the powers of 10
thing for sizes for you know distances
or for x and cosmology and stuff like
that I'm not gonna do that because you
can get that on the internet you can go
to Wikipedia and get that stuff but I
should just give you some numbers for
comparison so I wrote some numbers down
how many and so from now on so since we
know that approach
is about a GeV 10 to the 9 AV let's once
we get to the macroscopic scale use that
as our unit of measure how big is
something means how many proton or
neutron masses in it are in it which is
the number of protons and neutrons
roughly speaking
so a bacterium it turns out has about
the same number of protons and neutrons
as a single human DNA strand I think
this is true I mean I don't know I
looked it up on Wikipedia so a bacterium
or a human DNA strand bacteria have
their own DNA of course but it's shorter
than human is about 10 to the 12 protons
nowhere near Avogadro's number which is
a reflection of the fact that a
bacterium or a DNA is much smaller than
a gram that's not surprising a person
has about 10 to the 28 protons
most of us are more than one gram
sadly the earth not really sadly that
was a joke the earth is about 10 to the
51 protons again this is not the number
of protons in the earth this is the mass
of the earth in units of one proton mass
okay most of the earth is neutrons not
protons the Sun 10 to the 57 so I can
read my handwriting here the Milky Way
galaxy about 10 to the 76 it looks like
mass at 76 or 70s your homework how
heavy is the Milky Way and the
observable universe is about 10 to the
82 again don't trust me any of these
numbers because you know why I don't
care it doesn't really matter what these
exact numbers are of course it matters a
lot if you're a biologist or a chemist
or an astrophysicist or whatever all I'm
trying to do is emphasize
fact that once again the scaling
differences are enormous there's an
enormous hierarchy between the size of
the universe the size of a galaxy the
size of the solar system the size of a
person the size of a bacterium the size
of a proton that's interesting that's
interesting all by itself right why are
these hierarchies there you know part of
the whole philosophy of scaling is if
you have a certain mass scale out of
which everything else is created if you
didn't know anything else if you said
okay the world is made of protons and
neutrons and they have about the same
mass you might expect with good reason
that one or two or ten proton masses
would be a typical scale of stuff in the
universe right because that's what
everything else is built out of now it's
not true you know that everything else
is just is simply built out of protons
and neutrons this is part of the
explanation electrons are important
gravity is important and so forth but
the point is that therefore you demand
an explanation you want to know why
isn't everything roughly speaking one
proton mass where do these enormous
differences in sizes come from I'm not
gonna get to explain that all but will
give us some hints of where these
numbers come from along the way so this
is the appropriate time to get back into
that question of what is the physical
meaning of the conversion between energy
and mass and length and time okay what
does it mean when you say that a certain
distance is a certain number of inverse
electron volts and the answer comes in
the form of this idea called the Compton
wavelength of a particle the Compton
wavelength came out of analysis of
electromagnetic scattering by Arthur C
Compton Arthur C Compton Compton anyway
whatever his initials were but it
actually can be explained best if we
admit that individual particles are not
individual particles but come out of
quantum fields okay so the Compton
wavelength has a very simple definition
we're gonna use the letter lambda for it
I try to minimize my use of Greek
letters but lambda is just what we use
for wavelength sorry about that it's the
Greek version of L if you want that's
why length is appropriate and the
definition of the Compton wavelength of
a particle if I put all the constants
back in
is h-bar over the mass of the particle
times the speed of light we set H bar
and C equal to 1 so it's just 1 over the
mass of the particle ok so that's kind
of not very helpful
you just said okay I take the mass and I
invert it and I get the wavelength so
because distance or wavelength has units
of 1 over energy and mass has units of
energy this makes perfect sense units
wise ok I mean basically the Compton
wavelength is the mass except we're
expressing it in different units now why
why do we care about this particular
number first let me tell you what the
number is so the number for an electron
the Compton wavelength is about I'm
gonna give you one significant figure so
thank me for this 2 times 10 to the
minus 10 centimeters whereas for proton
Compton wavelength is about 1 times ten
to the minus thirteen centimeters now
that makes sense remember I told you an
electron and proton are different in
mass by a factor of about 1800 so if I
go to one significant bit you're a
factor of two thousand and here you go
there's the two thousand but what I want
to emphasize is the Compton wavelength
of a proton is shorter than the Compton
wavelength of an electron that's obvious
because it goes as 1 over the mass but
in ordinary ways of thinking in ordinary
world language you think of heavier
things as being bigger ok you have more
stuff in a heavy thing in order to put
more mass in something given the same
construction materials it will generally
take more size so we have this intuitive
feeling that heavier means not just more
massive but larger in physical dimension
but that's because we're imagining that
something is made out of some
pre-existing materials atoms arranged in
certain configurations this is different
the Compton wavelength I want to argue
is what you should think of when you
think of the size of an elementary
particle and in quantum mechanics
heavier particles are smaller in some
very real sense so let me actually
explain the sense in which the Compton
wavelength should be thought of as a
size so remember you have the
uncertainty principle
okay so you're relating the error were
you to measure the location of a
particle Delta x times Delta P the
uncertainty were you to measure the
position of the particle and we said
that it's greater than h-bar over two
but in my one order of magnitude
precision one half equals one okay two
equals one
only a particle physicist could get away
with that so you have to be careful when
you set two equal to one you better be
careful that it's really only two that
is you're setting equal to 1 not 2 to
the power 100 that would get you in
trouble because the to the power hunter
is very different than 1 to the power
hundred but if there's just a single
factor of 1/2 rolling around then we
ignore it and of course h-bar equals 1
so Delta X Delta P is greater than 1
that's the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle and we also have the
relativistic energy formula relating
energy to momentum we have the energy
squared equals the momentum squared this
is a vector of I'm gonna ignore the
vector signs plus the mass squared so
when the momentum is zero e squared
equals M squared or equals M the C
equals 1 and I've ignored all the other
factors of C etc there's factors of C
floating all around here if you try to
convert from momentum to velocity for
example okay
so consider a particle with zero
momentum let P equal 0 but imagine that
you have Delta P the uncertainty in the
momentum of order the mass okay so what
I'm saying here is imagine you have a
particle and it has a wave function so
we're not just thinking classical
particles within you a particle with a
quantum wave function and the wave
function might look like a wave packet
so here is sine as a function of X and
it's sort of flat and then it Wiggles
and is flat again okay so you have a
certain Delta X the size over which the
wave packet Wiggles before it goes to 0
to the left or to the right and if you
decomposed this wave packet
two modes with different wavelengths
you'll be able to figure out that
there's an uncertainty momentum as well
so I'm asking you to imagine that we
have a particle sort of in a more or
less confined region of space that we
know it's momentum on average is zero
but there's some uncertainty so there's
some contributions from zero momentum
some contributions from a small momentum
some contributions from large momentum
etc we're not exactly sure what answer
we would get were we to measure the size
of this particle the momentum of this
particle and let's imagine that that
momentum that uncertainty Delta P is of
the same order as the mass of the
particle okay we can do that one way of
saying it is if you were to measure the
energy right do you need to take into
account the fact that the momentum is
unknown so the energy that you might get
were you to measure it is likely to be
greater than two times M squared because
you have M squared itself and then you
have the contribution from the fact that
you don't know what momentum the
particle hands but what that means is
once the change in energy the
uncertainty in momentum becomes that
large the uncertainty in energy becomes
that large that you don't even know if
you only have one particle there right
once you get up to 4 M squared you have
enough energy to make an extra particle
if you know that what you're doing is
really quantum field theory you're not
quantum mechanics then you know that you
your quantum field is a superposition of
there are no particles there there's one
particle there there are two particles
there and so forth and here what you're
saying is you're probing at the particle
in such a way that you're not even sure
that what you will see is a single
particle anymore so the way to get
around this is to say the one particle
regime the part of the wave function of
the quantum field that really describes
really just one particle has the feature
that Delta P is less than M yes that's
correct
and therefore you look over at the
uncertainty principle so Delta x times
Delta P needs to be greater than one but
Delta P is less than M so therefore
Delta
my deltas are deteriorating sorry Delta
X has to be greater than one over m
otherwise you're not going to satisfy
the uncertainty principle so in other
words for the wave packet to have the
shape and size that lets you have enough
certainty about position about momentum
that you know you're not making new
particles the linear extent of the wave
packet has to be large enough that it's
larger than one over m which is of
course the Compton wavelength that's
what the Compton wavelength is I'm not
really not sure that was the most
elegant explanation of it ever given the
Compton wavelength is not necessarily
the wavelength of the actual wave
function of a particle it's the smallest
the wave function can be so that we can
actually know with high confidence that
there really is only just one particle
there it's the smallest box we can
squeeze a particle into and still stay
within this one particle regime in
quantum field theory if you try to
squeeze the particle smaller than that
or if you try to measure its position
with a precision higher than that then
you're not sure you're talking about
just one particle that's what the
Compton wavelength is there it is the
Compton wavelength one over the mass is
basically how small the particle this
wave function can be so we're sure it
really is just one particle so in other
words if you try to make something out
of particles you can't make things out
of individual particles with sizes
smaller than their Compton wavelength so
particles individual particles that you
would know and trust are really one
particle at a time can't be smaller than
the compliment wavelength I'll put a C
under there just to make sure that you
know is the Compton wavelength but if
I'm talking about individual particles I
will sometimes put the subscript for the
name of the particle okay so that's what
the Compton wavelength is it's sort of
the minimum size that you can squeeze
the wave function and you still call it
a particle so the bad news is there for
ant-man is not real
you know in the movies not just ant-man
but Fantastic Voyage many many movies
that you've seen in different contexts
there's the idea that you can take a
macroscopic thing like a person and just
shrink it right just make it smaller
now usually those thought experiments do
not tell you whether that happens
because the thing that you're making out
of has fewer and fewer atoms or because
the individual atoms are smaller okay
they're a little bit silent about that
but ant-man goes down all the way to the
size of an atom and therefore he's not
just a single atom so that's not
possible unless the individual atoms
became smaller and if that were true
they would have to become heavier if
you're making the Compton wavelengths of
these atoms tinier by the laws of
physics they would have to get more and
more massive so ant-man would actually
be enormous ly massive to have that many
atoms in his body squeezed down to that
tiny little size but that's not what he
is he's actually very light so that's
not realistic according to laws of
physics another way of spending the same
conclusion is you might wonder you know
there's human beings who live on planets
that circle the solar system the Sun and
then the Sun is part of that galaxy and
maybe the universe is part of something
bigger we seem to be in this nest of
hierarchy of many different things and
if you go small we're made of cells that
are made of molecules that are made of
atoms and you might casually ask
yourself I wonder if it just keeps going
my wonderful electrons are made of
tinier things and quarks are made of
tinier things I wonder if there could be
like a whole civilization that rises and
falls
on the surface of an electron just like
it does on the surface of the earth
going around the Sun no it can't
that's what this means that's what the
Compton wavelength tells you if you want
to stay in a regime where you're made of
particles where you're not just
high-energy wave functions then it's a
minimum size that your particle could
have given that it has a certain mass so
this is why we know that electrons and
other things are simple we have other
ways of knowing also but there's no
hidden amounts of variability in
electrons or anything like that if there
were little Wiggles and
wavefunction electron or extra wave
functions that also had really really
tiny wavelengths they would need to have
high energies and they would be more
massive than the electron so you can't
do it you got to keep your electrons
simple so size for elementary particles
is proportional to 1 over the mass
that's a crucial lesson that we got here
ok that's good for elementary particles
crucially important here because we know
this is not true for pickup trucks or
anything like that right more massive
things tend to be larger in the
macroscopic world so how do we relate
those two things you know where does
that where does the big size of
macroscopic things come from if the size
of individual particles comes from the
Compton wavelength remember again
particles can't be smaller than the
Compton wavelength but let's emphasize
particles and by which we mean the wave
function of a certain kind of particle
can be larger than the Compton
wavelength so the Compton wavelength is
a minimum size for particle nasubi a
sensible concept but they can be larger
and in fact they are so let's see for
example hydrogen you know you talked
about hydrogen atoms either atoms just a
single proton and electron going around
it if someone told you that someone says
okay here's physics here's a proton
here's an electron they're bound
together by electromagnetism how big
should the hydrogen atom be well you
have the Compton wavelength of the
electron which we said 2 times 10 to
minus 10 centimeters we have the Compton
wavelength of the proton ten to the
minus thirteen centimeters okay proton
much smaller than the electrons you
might say well the hydrogen atom should
be roughly the size of the electron so
it should be 2 times 10 to the minus 10
centimeters across now by dimensional
analysis I should I should note that we
can construct the number lambda P
divided by lambda
Compton wavelength the proton / the
Compton wavelength electron this is
about 10 to the minus 3 okay we're
getting the factor of 2 right now so
this is a dimensionless number and we
could raise it to any power if we raise
it to the power 10 then this is 10 to
minus 30 so scaling arguments only take
us so far when you have two masses in
the game or two Compton wavelengths two
lengths I'm gonna erase this because the
silly thing but you can create whatever
number you want in principle so you have
to think a little bit in other words
okay so let's do some thinking here
if the Compton wavelength of the proton
is tiny compared to the Compton
wavelength the electron even if you
don't say
if you don't leap to the conclusion that
the hydrogen atom should be the
comfortably length of the electron
there's no reason for the Compton
wavelength of the proton to have
anything to do with anything it's just a
very tiny little number we would
naturally expect if we even if we didn't
work through and solve the Schrodinger
equation that the proton was confined to
a more or less tiny little spot and the
electron was spread out over the atom
which is exactly true so in some sense
the thing that sets the scale for the
size of the hydrogen atom is the Compton
wavelength of the electron not the
proton and that's true but the question
is are there other things other
considerations that come into the game
well there is there is electromagnetism
okay
electromagnetism is what binds the
electron to the proton an
electromagnetism has a strength you can
think of the potential V of R ok the
electrostatic potential as a function of
the distance between two objects one way
of writing it and this is we're gonna
gloss over some constants of nature and
things like that is as minus alpha over
R where alpha is the fine-structure
constant 1 over 137 roughly okay so
alpha is the number that tells you the
strength of electromagnetism it tells
you how important the electromagnetic
force is when it comes to binding two
things together and 137 roughly 100 okay
so this is in an hour very sloppy way of
thinking 10 to the minus 2
so there's a factor of 10 to the -2 that
might come into the game when we figure
out what the size of something is right
that's a dimensionless number alpha
doesn't have any units at all we could
multiply it or we could divide it what
are we supposed to do well so we can
actually draw this potential very you
know again we're being a little bit
impressionistic here so here's our
here's V of R and R is the distance from
one object to another so by construction
it is a positive number or zero it can't
be a negative number
I'm gonna draw it as if it's negatives
that'll draw a three-dimensional thing
and the potential looks like this 1 over
R right again I'm a 1 over plus R down
here so that the potential is always a
negative number and the electron wants
to be near zero but because of the
uncertainty principle it will not be
exactly at zero and what what can we say
about the wave function of the electron
in the hydrogen atom so it's gonna look
something like this
right it's gonna be some spread out
thing if it were squeezed in more that
would cost energy from the change over
space for squeezed out less if we were
broader then it would be further away
from the proton where it doesn't want to
be so there is some give-and-take and
what we can say is we can just sort of
figure out how things should scale as
alpha goes to zero
so alpha never doesn't go to zero what
we mean is if we were to imagine a fake
world in which the fine-structure
constant were very very very very very
tiny how would that be different from
the real world well what it would mean
is the electron will be bound less
strongly there would be less of an
attraction between the electron and the
proton to make a hydrogen atom and
therefore what we would guess is that
how do I write this the size of the atom
would go to infinity right the electron
wants to be spread out that there's
micron in empty space there's an
electron if there's an electron that is
not bound to a proton it's one function
just spreads out as much as it can it's
much as it can that is the prediction of
the Schrodinger equation so as the
binding to the proton is artificially
turned off that electron would puff up
and become big
so that means that the size of the
hydrogen atom is inversely dependent on
the fine-structure constant so you might
guess
well let's not gas let's just tell you
the answer there's something called the
Bohr radius named after Niels Bohr who
figured it out long before quantum field
theory it was known or even quantum
mechanics was known they were inventing
it at the time the Bohr radius which is
traditionally called a knot which is a
terrible thing to call it but there's
other things that are called R and B and
so forth so a knot turns out to be the
Compton wavelength of the electron
divided by alpha because as alpha goes
to 0 the radius should get bigger so
divide it by alpha so that's 137 times
the Compton wavelength which works out
to be about 10 to the minus 8
centimeters so had you guessed that the
size of a hydrogen atom and the Bohr
radius is roughly speaking the size of a
hydrogen atom more specifically there's
no such thing as a hard fast wall at the
end of a hydrogen atom right if you look
at the yellow curve here it tails off
it's supposed to tail off gently it's
not supposed to cross the axis but the
play there's always some chance some
probability you'll find the electron if
you look for it anywhere so the Bohr
radius is the radius that says there's a
50-50 chance you'll find the electron
within the radius or outside the radius
so it is one way to characterize the
rough size of a hydrogen atom you might
have guessed naively that the hydrogen
atom should be the Compton wavelength of
the electron it's proportional to that
but the constant of proportionality is a
factor of a hundred so it is bigger and
that's because electromagnetism is weak
because the fine-structure constant is
small so in fact this is sometimes
called one angstrom unit 10 to the minus
8 centimeters an angstrom is just a very
convenient unit to use in atomic or
molecular physics is it's a size of a
hydrogen atom roughly speaking 10 to the
minus 8 centimeters and as it turns out
that's basically it it's not just
hydrogen that this is the size of this
is the Bohr radius is roughly the size
of a hydrogen atom it's also rough
the size of every other atom the atoms
do become bigger as you add more protons
and neutrons that nucleus becomes
heavier that's completely irrelevant to
the size because the nucleus is very
tiny the number of electrons though also
goes up that is relevant we'll talk
later about how electrons need to take
up different shells and so forth but
still you get factors of a few or
factors of 10 times bigger than the
hydrogen atom it's not linear with the
number of extra electrons so this is the
number time in my say 10 meters one
angstrom that sets the scale for atomic
physics for the length scale for atomic
physics the next thing you want to do is
put together more than one atom right
let's make a molecule and that's gonna
be you know life I'm not gonna do all of
molecules and chemistry and stuff like
that but we should be able to figure out
or at least say something about the
energies that are associated with
molecules so to do that let's figure out
something about the energy associated
with individual atoms right so we drew
this potential here for the electron
this is the potential energy of an
electron
surrounded by the in the vicinity of a
single proton and you know remember we
did the simple harmonic oscillator
remember oops yeah remember what I wanna
do here come on open up remember simple
harmonic oscillator was a thing where we
had a potential that was a parabola x
squared and we said that the energy
levels were equally spaced
there were energy levels en that were
basically proportional to n in fact n
plus 1/2 if you really want to be sticky
about it but they were equally spaced so
you could have an infinite number of
energy levels in the harmonic oscillator
I'm not gonna draw the wave functions
again but do you member I've drawn them
before and there's an infinite number of
them they go infinitely high same thing
is true for the Coulomb potential as we
call it Coulomb potential is the
potential one over arm minus alpha over
R so the potential itself looks like
this oops that wasn't very good as a
function of R but the energy levels have
a slightly different
behavior the energy levels e n are
proportional to minus 1 over N squared
I'm sorry that alpha is used for
proportionality and for the
fine-structure constant once again but
basically there is a lowest energy level
e 1 and this is works out to be thirteen
point six electron volts so the
difference between the energy of an
electron that is outside the hydrogen
atom not in it at all and the energy of
a electron that is in its lowest energy
state inside the hydrogen atom is
thirteen point six electron volts but
then that's a 1 and then e2 is closer to
outside and then a 345 and they pile up
there are also an infinite number of
energy levels that an electron can have
in a hydrogen atom but as the number
gets higher is the number that we use to
characterize which energy level were in
they get closer and closer to zero
difference between being in the atom and
being outside what that means physically
is any little perturbation will just
kick the electron right out so an
electron is lowest energy level is stuck
inside the hydrogen atom as much as it
can be stuck it takes this much energy
thirteen point six electron volts to
kick it out and set it free whereas the
if an electron is up here in a higher
energy level it's easier to kick it out
is bound more loosely it is larger you
know its wavefunction is more spread out
and it's less tightly bound to the
proton what will happen if you just have
an electron all by itself in a high
energy level is generally will give off
a photon and go down to the lower energy
level so electrons tend to settle down
to lower energy levels now this number
thirteen point six evie where did that
come from I mean remember the mass of
the electron is something like 5 times
10 to the 5 electron volts
so there's another big hierarchy here
between the mass of the electron and the
energy the binding energy is thirteen
point six EB is the binding energy or
the ionization energy of an electron in
a hydrogen atom where did that come from
well we know that the energy
of an electron the just the energy
classically speaking is the potential
energy and we know what that is it's
minus alpha over R right the energy V of
our potential energy is minus alpha over
R and we know that the typical are the
average value R is the Bohr radius a
naught and a naught where is it lambda
over alpha so the energy is roughly
speaking alpha over R R is lambda over
alpha this is alpha squared over lambda
or in other words alpha squared times
the mass of the electron so there is
this energy scale given to us by the
mass of the electron but science inserts
a factor of alpha squared which is 10 to
the minus 4 in fact it's a little bit
smaller than 10 to the minus 4 so that
takes us down from 5 times 10 to the
minus 5 times 10 to the 5 electron volts
all the way down to just thirteen point
six electron volts so it's two factors
of the fine-structure constant that's
where this particular hierarchy comes
from and this is why again you know this
is a pretty good energy this is this is
as close as that one electron can get to
the proton it has we will talk about
later you know in chemistry in heavier
elements there will be some electrons
that are stuck there close to the
nucleus and the nucleus is more charged
in a heavier element like carbon or iron
or whatever so the most bound electrons
are more tightly bound in carbon or iron
than they are in hydrogen but they are
also irrelevant to chemistry okay
because they're just staying there
chemistry is all the excitement because
of the electrons in the outer shells of
the atom and they are less tightly bound
then this one is so basically the energy
scales of chemistry all of chemistry
happens at energy scales of between 1
and 10 electron volts
roughly speaking okay again very very
roughly but and this is why because it's
the mass of the electron times two
factors of alpha times again some extra
factors of N and N squared and things
like that when you get to higher and
higher energy levels so this is how
hierarchies get built because there's a
one number the fine-structure constant
that is a little bit small ten to the
minus two and it comes in multiple times
that's what we're atoms get their energy
from what about molecules hmm molecules
it's a very similar story the only thing
we have to play with are the masses of
the nuclei the protons and the neutrons
the masses the electrons and the
fine-structure constant but they get
hooked up together in more and more
complicated ways happily the answer
works out very easily I'm not gonna
actually try to justify this answer both
tell you what it is so you can see once
again this hierarchy at work so you can
have in molecules let's say that you
have very simple molecule let's say you
have one atom that is just bound to
another atom well one thing is that
these two atoms can vibrate right they
can simply go back and forth you will
not be surprised to learn that for small
vibrations the energy of that kind of
vibration looks like a simple harmonic
oscillator because everything looks like
a sub armonica oscillator when it is
small vibrations small vibrations just
look like harmonic oscillators so
there's a lowest energy and next highest
energy etc vibrational energies are
typically something like 10 to the minus
2 electron volts okay things are a
little bit farther apart larger
distances means lower energies because
distance goes inversely proportional to
energy
there are also rotations so let's
imagine we have a more complicated
molecule let's imagine a little molecule
that has you know three different this
is a heavy nucleus maybe this is methane
or something like that right no ammonia
sorry well this is a heavy nucleus and
three hydrogen atoms and if we work in a
frame of reference where we fix this one
and don't move it the one at the bottom
sorry now that the other two move over
it's very much like when we said when
you have a wave any arbitrary wave can
be written as a superposition of plane
waves with fixed wavelengths sine waves
and cosines okay those that set of
things you can add together to get any
wave at all we called the modes okay
here we have an interesting geometry but
the same kind of analysis applies
there's certain fundamental modes of
oscillation from which you can build
everything that actually happens so if
you think about if you just fix your
reference frame by fixing the bottom
most atom and let the top most atoms
move around what can they do they can
oscillate in and out but they can also
lastly in and out either in phase or in
opposite phase to each other okay that's
sort of elongating or shrinking I guess
they can move apart from each other back
and forth
or they can sort of wiggle in concert
and they can also have one go toward you
and away and vice versa or they can go
toward you in a way in concert also so
there's a bunch of fundamental things
that the molecule can do and they have a
fundamental kind of energy so the
rotation the whole thing can rotate
around also or distortion of the
molecules also have a typical energy
scale maybe 10 to the minus 3 electron
volts again like more moving parts means
that it's slower means that it's larger
so bigger spatial scales bigger temporal
scales means lower energy scales so
that's what you get I'm not deriving the
number but I'm trying to justify that's
basically where it comes from and from
that of course the real world is built
out of much much heavier complicated
molecules than that so you get even
lower and lower energies once you get
the long hydrocarbon chains they can
wiggle around they have all sorts of
different modes so what I would like to
do is talk about not just so these are
individual molecules the next step would
be to go from molecules to more
complicated things alas I have a lot
things to say about more complicated
thing
it's like living organisms and
complicated things where you can see
structure where you can see complexity
your eyes and stuff like that I have
enough things that I think that it's
pretty clear that I should just do a
separate video on them so I'm gonna stop
this one here and this is the the
discussion we've done on scaling I hope
that some people aren't upset because
there's a whole nother discussion to
have on scaling that is just much more
macroscopic from the start and you know
how does the heartbeat of an animal
scale with its body mass or things like
that and I do want to talk about that
because it is a big idea in the universe
but for this one you know just a home
you know there are two main points I
wanted to get across one was this big
set of hierarchies in fundamental
particle physics which some of it we
understand some of it we don't and all
actually I didn't try very hard to
explain this hierarchy you know I put an
electron together with a proton to get a
hydrogen atom but I didn't tell you why
electrons are much lighter than the
Higgs boson or why the proton is much is
similar to the Higgs boson within a
factor of 100 but we'll get there
this is one thing I want to talk about
and this is really the other thing I
want to talk about the idea of the
Compton wavelength and how it sets the
scale for elementary particles and then
by multiplying by effect factors of
alpha in the correct way we go from that
Compton wavelength to the size of atoms
hydrogen but also other atoms it works
for and then you just multiply by alpha
again to get the energy of the different
things that can happen inside an atom so
all these different scales these
hierarchies are built up by making more
complicated things out of simple things
and there are rules behind them sorry
about ant-man not being real but there
are other things equally cool in quantum
mechanics in the universe so I hope that
the reality is just as interesting as
the Marvel movies